chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire je suis allée de chômeurs et
chaque semaine dans l'échiquier mondial
nous analyserons les coups les plus
complexes du jeu politique
internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
le nombre d'admis en réanimation et le
nombre de morts en baisse en france avec
un pic attendu la semaine prochaine
il y a eu 4 141 décès ces dernières 24
heures à l'hôpital plus de 2000 ans mise
en retraite depuis le 1er mars le
ministre de la santé qui a révisé
aujourd'hui sa doctrine il s'agit à
présent d'équiper tous les français de
masques de protection pour envisager la
sortie
et en ce premier week-end de vacances de
pâques 160 mille policiers des gendarmes
sont déployés pour faire respecter le
confinement
cinq personnes blessées et deux morts
dans une attaque au couteau dans la
drôme un réfugié soudanais de 33 ans en
est pris à plusieurs personnes dans le
centre-ville de romans sur isère en fin
de matinée il a été interpellé par une
équipe de police secours alors qu'il
s'était agenouillé pour faire une prière
en langue arabe
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est rendu
sur place le parquet antiterroriste est
saisie
[Musique]
la pandémie dans le monde a tué plus de
60000 personnes et l'espoir peut-être
d'un ralentissement en europe
continentale après plus de 14 mille cinq
cents morts en italie plus de dix mille
en espagne pour la première fois depuis
le début de la propagation du virus l'
oms fait volte face
le port d'une protection faciale et
maintenant recommandé par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce soir le nombre de
personnes admises en réanimation est en
baisse en france ces derniers jours des
hôpitaux qui sont donc légèrement moins
sous tension les spécialistes
s'attendent même à une stagnation de
l'épidémie la semaine prochaine le bilan
ce soir est de plus de 7500 60 morts
dans les hôpitaux et les maisons de
retraites comprises depuis le début du
mois de mars la 6838 personnes sont
toujours en réanimation ce soir le
ministre de la santé qui a alerté
aujourd'hui également sur les personnes
en situation de handicap
ce ne doit pas être un critère de refus
d'admission à l'hôpital at il déclaré il
fit le gouvernement français qui après
l'avoir fortement déconseillé on s'en
souvient préconise maintenant le port
d'une protection faciale quelle qu'elle
soit l'état qui a également interdit
souvenez-vous la préconisation de la
chloroquine pour les cas précoce de kobe
de 19 par les médecins de ville
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de grands
spécialistes du monde médical appellent
le gouvernement à revenir sur sa
décision
ils ont signé un manifeste dans un
quotidien français aujourd'hui et parmi
les signataires à l'un des premiers
défenseurs de la méthode du professeur
raoul tu il s'agit de l'ancien ministre
de la santé philippe douste-blazy
il est absolument nécessaire si vous
voulez d'agir
nous avons d'un côté le professeur awa
qui nous montrent autant sonné avec son
équipe qu'il n'y a plus de charge virale
au bout de cinq jours chez les patients
qui ne sont donc plus contagieux et qui
d'autre part s'améliore considérablement
et non pas de complication nous avons
l'agent du médicament américaine a évité
la coupure la plus sévère la plus
exigeante qui au vu de ces résultats
accepte que tous les médecins
hospitaliers amical puisse en donner à
leurs patients dans des formes qui ne
sont pas justement sévère car quand
c'est sévère leadership taureau qui ne
marche pas enfin on a le taux de
mortalité à marseille
la houle
round traite ses passions très
rapidement des clients positif le taux
de mortalité à marseille le plus bas de
très loin de tout le territoire national
donc tout ça mis bout à bout associé à
une est équipé étude chinoise qui montre
avec un groupe contrôle qui ne prenaient
pas les trucs si chloroquine qu'il y
avait une amélioration majeure dans le
groupe et donc cycloclean oui avec
beaucoup de médecins avec des grands
professeurs de médecine qui
appartiennent à l'académie nationale de
france de médecine
nous avons fait une pétition pour que
les françaises et les français nous elle
à ce que dans les hôpitaux les médecins
puissent donner s'ils le veulent
dès ce genre de médicaments car sinon
nous n'avons bien nous sommes dépourvus
nous ne pouvons rien donné à ses
patients et avec ton de décider de
quelle passé dans le cycle et rockit
comme un poison nous en donnons depuis
50 ans faisons un électorat de g avant
surtout dit à tout le monde ne jamais
faire de l'auto médication que des
médecins savent ce qu'il faut et qu'ils
puissent prescrire ce médicament et en
seine saint denis le taux de mortalité
est en forte hausse + 63 % de morts en
une seule semaine du 21 au 27 mars par
rapport à la semaine précédente
jeudi le directeur de la santé jérôme
salomon avait évoqué un excès de
mortalité dans ce département
précisément l épidémie qui si fortement
propager 940 personnes sont mortes le 30
mars dernier contre 643 à la même date
l'an dernier
des chiffres publiés par l'institut
national de la statistique qui prenne en
compte toutes les personnes décédées
qu'elle soit morte du coronavirus ou pas
vous voyez ce qu'on dit fabien gay il
est sénateur pcf de seine saint denis
nous sommes moins bien doté que le reste
de l'ile-de-france dans tous les
domaines dans tous les services publics
et notamment nos services publics
hospitaliers qui manque de
qui manquent de matériel comme partout
sur le territoire mais encore plus
sincères ni celles et ceux qu'on appelle
les invisibles celles et ceux en réalité
qui sont nos premiers de cordée dans
cette crise sanitaire beaucoup amis dans
cette scène et beaucoup sont au travail
aujourd'hui ce sont des soignantes
ce sont des aides-soignantes ce sont des
livreurs ce sont des gens laissés bouard
ce sont celles et ceux qui font vivre
nos supermarchés notamment les
caissières les caissiers je rappelle
qu'il ya maintenant quelques mois le
premier ministre avait dit pour la
première fois que l'état reconnaissait
des défaillances en seine saint denis
dans tous les services publics et que
contrairement à ce que l'on croit
il y a moins ce que le service public
est moins d'argent en seine saint denis
cornil de que partout ailleurs en france
et notamment en ile de france et ses
inégalités très forte que nous vivons au
quotidien et qui ressorte encore plus
forte au moment d'une crise sanitaire
une épidémie mondiale qui n'épargne pas
les petites communes françaises c'est le
cas vous allez le voir dans un petit
village du pas de calais 515 habitants
et le maire pharmacien de profession
prend les choses très au sérieux
le reportage de thomas bonnet emma
simard deros je ne veux pas
que tu touches aux boîtes aux lettres
comme ça je te mettrai une boîte de
grands noms zéro risque zéro risque
voilà une formule qui résume assez bien
la doctrine mise en place par michel
petit pour preuve avant de nous
accueillir dans sa commune le maire nous
a donné quelques recommandations
il nous a été demandé de respecter des
conditions assez drastiques comme le
port de sète sur blues du masque
évidemment pour rencontrer donc ce mr
particulièrement précautionneux
il faut dire que avant d'être le maire
de cette commune d'un peu plus de 500
habitants
michel petit et avant tout pharmacien de
formation depuis le début de l'épidémie
michel petit a distribué plusieurs
circulaire à l'attention de ses
administrés le but sensibiliser tout le
monde sur les gestes à adopter
on doit changer tous nos gestes
habituels
on a des habitudes même moi j'ai parfois
des difficultés à les appliquer je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est bien ancrée c'est
bien ancrée dans l'est dans les esprits
une mission que michel petit assure en
tant que maire mais aussi en tant que
pharmacien
nous le retrouvons devant son officine
le voici en pleine discussion avec un
médecin de la région
dès que je les ai je te préviens si tu
veux du soluté hydroalcoolique qu'on en
sache particulièrement vigilants et
précautionneux michel petit lait aussi à
l'intérieur de sa pharmacie alors dans
l'officine
il y a trois fils 2 pour les patients
une pour les professionnels de santé
c'est-à-dire les infirmières ou les
médecins qui viennent au quotidien le
mât le matin des distances à respecter
de 1 mètre 50
et vous voyez ici les gens ne peuvent
pas poser leur sac ou hot sur les
comptoirs c'est pour ça que nous avons
mis des balises
on pourrait dire que c'est un excès de
zèle mais moi je pense aux personnes qui
sont vraiment offrons aux urgentistes
ont médecin réanimateur aux infirmières
il n'y a pas besoin de surcharge de
travail certes rassurés par les mesures
de précaution prises par le maire les
habitants du village restent toutefois
inquiets
au-delà de l'aspect sanitaire c'est
l'impact économique qui est dans tous
les esprits qui nous par la force des
choses on a mis pratiquement 80% de
notre personnel à l'arrêt on devra
également avancé les salaires du mois
d'avril
le souci étant c'est que les avancées
oui quand on n'a pas de trésorerie
c'est bien nous on en a un petit peu
donc on va pouvoir assurer mars et avril
mais après on ne sait pas parce que je
connais pas du tout les délais
aujourd'hui de remboursement de 2 c de c
avant ce qu'on va faire sur le chômage
partiel
on a perdu énormément
au niveau de notre activité on faisait
des prestations traiteur qui sont
totalement annulée au jour d'aujourd'hui
donc on s'est rabattu sur notre activité
de boucherie c'est pas évident avec le
confinement
parce que nous on fait les marchés tous
les jours dans les mines et sur le
secteur d'arras tous les marchés ont été
annulés aussi alors je vous l'accordé
image de la commune de berles au bois
vidée de ses habitants c'est un peu
moins saisissant visuellement que les
champs-elysées vidées de leurs touristes
mais pourtant ici aussi les mesures de
confinement sont respectés ont un impact
sur la vie quotidienne des habitants
aucun cas de covin 19 n'a pour l'heure
été détectée ici mais dans les communes
avoisinantes il ya des personnes qui ont
été testées positives et malgré toutes
les mesures de précaution prises par le
maire du village
il s'attend à ce qu'il sait aussi des
personnes soient touchées par cette
épidémie la colère du syndicat de la
police scientifique suite aux propos de
christophe castaner tenue le 1er avril
dernier le ministre de l'intérieur qui
avait annoncé une possible contribution
des services de la police scientifique
dans le dépistage du commis de 19 et
bien les syndicats affirment ne pas en
avoir les moyens techniques pour
recevoir notamment les malades
il annonce tout de même être prêt à
aider leurs concitoyens
écoutez la réaction de soizic henriot
référente de l'institut national de
police scientifique pour le syndicat
snipat techniquement c'est assez
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre
si on dispose d'un certain des matériels
qui peuvent être utilisés pour ce type
d'intervention c'est à dire détecter et
analyser des tests de kobe 19 ou ne
disposent pas forcément du savoir faire
et ça créé tout un ensemble de
complications pour notre mission
première qui est l'identification des
auteurs sur les crimes et les délits
rappelons le quand même le coc vite
c'est un un virus à arn pour faire les
tests vocaux vite si je ne m'abuse
il faut faire des pcr de quantification
mais sûr de la rn donc on ne dispose pas
des produits ne dispose pas des kits
adéquat on nous on dispose du matériel
qu'il faudrait régler et qu'il faut
adapter pour faire ce type d'analysé on
n'a pas les réactifs
on n'a pas les savoir-faire et xsara
il faut lui mettre au point donc ça se
fait pas en claquant des doigts comme
comme monsieur le ministre l'a annoncé
dans la presse cette semaine
à la une également en france cette
attaque au couteau qui a eu lieu à
romans-sur-isère dans la drôme en fin de
matinée le bilan est de deux morts et de
cinq blessés
l'assaillant a été interpellé et le
parquet national anti terroriste s'est
saisi de l'enquêté
et puis sachez que le président de la
république a également réagi sur son
réseau social
voici ses mots toute la lumière sera
faite sur cet acte odieux qui vient
d'endeuiller notre pays déjà être
durement éprouvée ces dernières semaines
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
également rendu sur place
aujourd'hui écoutez le il appartiendra
immédiatement à nos services de plus
judiciaire de conduire l'anc est sous
l'autorité du procureur local en lien
permanent avec le procureur national
anti terroriste qui évaluent l'ensemble
des faits et sera amené à se prononcer
sur la qualification terroriste ou pas
il lui appartient à lui seul de le faire
ce qui s'est passé ici est un drame
l'enquète devra donner toute la vérité
est évidemment nous engageons à ce que
tous les moyens soient mobilisés pour
garantir à chacun la sécurité immédiate
et pour garantir toute la vérité de
l'enquète envoyer les précisions de
notre spécialiste sécurité antoine
boitel j'ai contacté un ancien
commandant de police qui s'appelle
jean-pierre colombiès qui est
porte-parole d'une association de
policiers en colère et qui m'a fait part
de ses observations en tant que ancien
commandant de police lui ce qui m'a dit
c'est que à son sens avec la crise
sanitaire on est dans le pire des
scénarios possibles actuellement puisque
la menace terroriste est toujours au
dessus de nos têtes comme une épée de
damoclès tandis qu' on essaie de lutter
également contre le coc u19 donc la
question bien sûr on vient de voir
christophe castaner s'exprimer ça nous
rappelle l' attaque terroriste qui avait
lieu au coeur de la préfecture de police
de paris
des collègues la question c'est toujours
de savoir si le parti national
antiterroriste à être saisies ou pas
depuis qu'il se parquer existe depuis
2010 9
il semblerait qu'ils travaillent déjà en
lien en fait avec le parquet local
donc en réalité quand jean-pierre
colombiès en plus ferme at il dit aucun
doute que le parquet national anti
drogue sera saisie
cependant on l'est on laisse un peu le
doute persiste et ça c'est devenu un peu
la norme on dirait la question qu'on
peut se poser également c'est de savoir
si l'assaillant est fou le comment dire
le motif et psychiatrique ce que m'a dit
jean-pierre colombiès à cet égard c'est
que selon lui oui il est fou les fous
comme tous les autres fous de dieu il
l'a fait il a fait part également de 10
ans extatique de la religion à son sens
si c'est bien un motif religieux qui
devait être retenue il m'a aussi dit que
on faisait semblant depuis des longues
années lui-même ayant 30 ans de police
derrière lui de ne pas voir le problème
réel une faute de ne pas l'avoir traité
auparavant à son sens et comme en france
en italie le nombre d'hospitalisations
en soins intensifs diminue pour la
première fois depuis le début de
l'épidémie le nombre est repassé sous la
barre des 4000 hospitalisation avec 3996
admission exactement dans ce pays le
plus durement touché de l'union
européenne le président du conseil
italien a appelé lieu à être plus
ambitieuse plus unie et plus courageuse
giuseppe compter répondait ainsi à la
président de la commission européenne
qui s'était excusé auprès des italiens
du manque des aides apportées par les
pays membres
ursula von der leyen a promis 100
milliards d'euros aux pays les plus
impactés économiquement plus de
précisions sur la situation en italie ce
soir avec michele marzo qu'ici les
médecins généralistes à milan il
tremblait principal enseignement c'est
que les hôpitaux ils sont déjà engagées
il ya pas de la sony faisant des progrès
7 - suivre les meilleurs et ce relais et
son pouvoir dans la maison et danser
c'est pourquoi nous gérons licenciement
souray et pour avoir des eyzies pas
seulement les veut garder que par l'udc
et un certain nombre de personnes qu'un
saut il y allait pas recommander aux
gens s'ils sont déjà beaucoup reprise et
donc voilà on cherche de ralentir un
texan emmerder les gens mais en le mieux
étant sa principale et j'ai seulement
besoin un signe d'espoir en espagne avec
un nombre de morts également à la baisse
pour le deuxième jour consécutif les
autorités ont enregistré ce matin 809
décès en moins en moins de 24 heures et
près de 125 mille cas confirmés
l'hôpital campagne le plus grand
d'espagne est situé à madrid il
accueille plus d'un millier de patients
le chef du gouvernement pedro sanchez a
annoncé la prolongation pour deux
semaines du confinement
il ira donc jusqu'au 25 avril inclus
voyez les précisions d'une des
responsables du centre d'urgence
sanitaire elle l'emmène au total
au total le nombre de cas confirmés de
kovy de 19 et 224 1736 soit 700 milles
26 de plus que hier sur la base de ces
chiffres
l'augmentation du nombre de cas est
aujourd'hui de 6 % par rapport à hier et
cela confirme pour un autre jour la
tendance à la baisse que nous observer
jusqu'à présent le nombre de décès et de
11 1744 dont 809 décès hier l'espagne
qui a déclaré l'état d'alerté le 14 mars
dernier et qui a déployé l'armée pour
lutter contre la couronne à virus ce
sont des militaires qui ont contribué
notamment à l'édification du plus grand
hôpital de campagne à madrid à pampelune
pourtant vous voyez certains espagnols
les ont hués de leur balcon alors qu'ils
effectuaient des contrôles de
confinement des soldats présents dans
toutes les régions d'espagne pour
également transporter les morts
ou désinfecter les bâtiments écoutez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et au royaume uni il y a un peu plus de
700 morts de plus en 24 heures ce qui
porte le bilan à 4300 décès et cas
exceptionnel aujourd'hui à un enfant de
5 ans est décédé du coronavirus la plus
jeune victime au royaume uni était
jusqu'à présent un adolescent
britannique âgé de 13 ans morse le 30
mars dernier à londres la reine doit
prononcer un discours à la nation demain
dans la capitale un immense hôpital de
campagne vous voyez a été inaugurée hier
pour accueillir l'afflux croissant de
malades il a été bâti avec l'aide de
l'armée là aussi il aura une capacité de
4000 lits d'autres hôpitaux de ce type
doivent être remontés dans les prochains
jours direction l équateur à présent où
la situation est plutôt alarmante au
moins 40 % des malades du coronavirus ne
respecteraient pas leurs quarantaine
résultat le président lenin moreno a
décidé de recourir à une surveillance
technologique des personnes contaminées
l équateur qui a également ordonné la
fermeture des écoles le confinement il a
fermé ses frontières et instauré un
couvre feu dans la région de guayas
c'est la région la plus touchée
au total et le pays compte plus de 3300
cas et 145 morts
avec 70 personnes contaminées madagascar
est pour l'instant relativement épargnée
lille prend tout de même des mesures
adéquates ses frontières ont été fermées
depuis le 19 mars
les habitants des grandes villes des
pays sont confinés dans les régions les
plus reculées aussi la lutte contre la
pandémie vous allez le voir s'organise
un abbé licence et robin qu elle au
nord-ouest de madagascar l'île de nosy
komba est une destination prisée des
touristes avec 45000 visiteurs par an si
l'on prend en compte la fréquentation de
l'île voisine de nocibé la région serait
particulièrement exposée en cas
d'épidémie car la petite île volcanique
accessible seulement pirogue ne compte
pas d'hôpital le suivi médical et
seulement assurée par un généraliste et
une sage-femme au sein d'un dispensaire
en pleine pandémie mondiale nos six
combats doit donc se prémunir contre les
risques présentés par l'arrivée de
touristes venus de zones à risque dont
les hôtels les employés appliquent les
consignes sanitaires
à leur arrivée les touristes doivent se
présenter à l'équipe médicale est un
généraliste décide de la nécessité ou
pas de procéder à un dépistage avec
seulement 100 kits de test rapide
disponible sur l'île voisine de nocibé
seuls les touristes arrivés avant la
fermeture des frontières
ils ont été contraints cette semaine
trois ressortissants français en
provenance de la réunion ont fait
l'objet d'un dépistage
ces touristes ont été testés négatifs
ils ont donc pu sortir de la quarantaine
décidées par le gouvernement malgache
des mesures de précaution que ces
touristes ont volontiers accepté pour
gagner la confiance de la population
je pense que ça va bien rassuré tout le
monde le fait qu'on se prête au jeu bas
de la quarantaine déjà et depuis le test
à chaque fois qu'on a été convoqué par
le tourbillon à respecter
les différentes directives et ça ça a
bien assuré le village et ça nous a
permis d'être acceptée respecter pour ça
je pense le cas contraire serait pas été
bon pour nous je pense
on a discuté avec des gens qui sont à
nos cibles et qu'ils sont et une tension
qu'on a pas ressenti réellement à part
le premier soit après la quarantaine mai
sortie à pas de velours
est ce que c'est bon ça fait est ce que
les gens ont peur de nous puis on fait
ça c'est l'idée contraire pour l'heure
il est préservé du coville 19 et entend
bien le rester mais elle subit tout de
même les conséquences de l'épidémie
coupé de la majorité de ses revenus
touristiques depuis près d'un mois
nos six combats s'enfonce peu à peu dans
la crise économique
l'afrique du sud est elle compte neuf
morts à ce stade et pour connaître
précisément le nombre de contaminations
le pays augmente peu à peu sa capacité
de dépistage infirmières et
aides-soignants sont sur le terrain vous
le voyez dans les rues de johannesburg
des tests gratuits et des tests mobiles
ont été installés ainsi que des
enceintes privées pour des tests payant
cette fois d
initiatives qui se multiplient écoutez
[Musique]
c'est notre travail et notre volonté de
faire des kilomètres pour et de nos
quartiers
on prend des précautions parce qu'on est
aussi des êtres humains mais on veut
être là dans les quartiers oui à on
essaie de sensibiliser les gens parce
que certains d'entre eux ne comprennent
pas ce confinement
c'est du jamais vu en afrique du sud
c'est nouveau pour la plupart des gens
et en chine l'hommage aux morts du
coronavirus aujourd'hui en particulier a
eu and d'où est partie la pandémie
mondiale
trois minutes de silence ont été
observées les sirènes des ambulances ont
été activés les voitures les trains et
les bateaux ont également fait retentir
leur klaxon
la chine qui a donc observer une journée
de deuil national en hommage aux plus de
3300 personnes qui sont décédées du
courant d'un virus les professionnels de
santé ils ont été érigées en véritables
héros
écoutez les nous avons remporté une
victoire temporaire dans cette lutte
contre l'épidémie
notre hôpital est un établissement qui
accueille des patients dans d état
critique est sévère et nous accueillons
encore quelques patients pour l'instant
on ne peut pas se détendre
nous essuyons nos larmes et conserverons
notre capacité à agir jusqu'à ce que
nous remportions la victoire ultime de
cette guerre
mon coeur est rempli de chagrin
aujourd'hui en assistant à cet événement
commémoratif pour pleurer nos camarades
et nos compagnons d'armes qui ont
disparu nous restons fidèles à nos
postes en première ligne et nous
continuerons à travailler dur pour
sauver des patients jusqu'à la dernière
minute et cette question à présent la
pandémie de qu'ovide 19 est elle propice
à la censure sur les réseaux sociaux et
bien la réponse pourrait être oui
puisque le président brésilien et
l'ancien maire de new york rudolph
giuliani on aurait fait les frais il
avait vanté les mérites de
l'hydro xi chloroquine contre locaux
vides 19 dans des vidéos qui ont été
supprimés les deux géants américains
twitter ou facebook multiplie ses
suppression de contenus liés aux copies
de 19
cela a été le cas notamment pour le
président du venezuela
voyez ce qu'en dit fabrice epelboin il
est professeur à sciences po et
spécialiste des médias sociaux
on peut parler d'une crypte tentatives
pour l'europe de reprendre la main sur
l'opinion publique des populations
européennes essaient des tentatives qui
sont d'une part assez maladroite et puis
d'autre part on peut vraiment se
demander si facebook est en mesure de
proposer ça où l'europe et même si elle
en a un intérêt stratégique si on
considère que facebook est un acteur
géopolitique la france provenant dans la
situation la pire qui soit en europe
elle est partie avec un capital de
confiance pour leur politique était déjà
extrêmement bas et même le rebond qu'à
donner la crise n'est pas suffisant pour
faire passer le président bacon dans un
une zone de confort on va dire où ils
auraient au moins la moitié de la
population qui lui ferait confiance mais
on en n'est même pas là et on au début
du profil bas et c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité sur
notre antenne
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes restez
avec nous
[Musique]
il y a une problématique d'augmentation
extrêmement importante de la demande en
eau depuis la révolution verte qui a
conduit à cette autosuffisance
alimentaire de l'inde dans ces zones
climatiques aride il ya quasiment plus
d'eau en surface
on compte maintenant après sur le pays
de l'ordre de 25 millions depuis qu'on
paie ce qui est six fois plus que la
chine
cette image une femme qui porte un pont
à eau sur la tête et une image